dies verunsichert aber man sieht die
augen immer noch also das ist auf jeden
fall immens carey und das wegen
halloween special oder so auf jeden fall
hammergeil damit auf einen man sieht nur
so augen irgendwie unisys krass ey leute
und herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen
minecraft facts folge und zwar zu k 10
uhr sind in einem special
und oh mein gott das letzte das hühnchen
verletzter folge was umgekehrt war ich
bin sagen wir gehen mit übernahmen wegen
wie können wir das denn ich glaube ich
würde sagen wenn das mal creepy
wahlkrimi heißt so etwas wie verrückt
oder angst einflößen oder komisch das
ist das hühnchen creepy schreibt
wahlkrimi in die kommentare begrüßen wir
krieg in unserer crew egal los gehts ja
man und zwar kommen wir direkt zum
ersten effekt und zwar fällt der
charakter von einem schneller als das
item wenn man das runter wird also ich
möchte mich mal runter und ich bin halt
viel schneller als das und das kommt da
erst an zum beispiel wir können das noch
mal machen dass das scheißegal was von
altem ich hab' ich kann theoretisch auch
etliches regnet gaal sich daran stören
ich könnte theoretisch auch einen vollen
eimer mit wasser oder irgendeine amboss
oder so alle items sind in minecraft
gleich schwer egal ob es ein fehler ist
oder ob es ein eisenwaren ist das wäre
doch witzig wenn das irgendwie zugefügt
werden könnte das die verschiedenen
schnelligkeit haben sodass der eimer der
kommt jetzt darunter da ist der eimer
also der charakter ist grundsätzlich
vetter als irgendwie ein amboss oder
schaafs ponys oder eben alles mögliche
andere weil es der charaktere von einem
selber fällt natürlich schneller als ein
item so fakt nummer 21 bzw
besagt mehr oder weniger das wenn ich
auf eine spinne einen unsichtbarkeit
trank während ich hab hier erwerbbaren
trank der unsichtbarkeit sechs minuten
lang
wenn ich dir noch die drauf wer sieht
man trotzdem noch die augen von der
spiele also ich werfe das zum beispiel
da drauf und man sieht trotzdem noch da
ich weiß nicht aber man sieht so ganz
ganz leicht die auge ich mach das mal
ganz kurz
vielleicht sieht man das bei nacht
besser sein
right time after time satellite times at
night eventuell sieht man es dabei
besser wusste denn da sieht man immer
noch die augen so ein bisschen seht ihr
das stockmann konstanz gut sehen dass
man die spinne die ist zwar unsichtbar
aber man sieht die augen immer noch also
das ist auf jeden fall immens gary und
deswegen halloween special oder so auf
jeden fall hammergeil das sondern auf
amazon man sieht nur so augen ihm die
ubs kraft so kommen wir auch direkt
weiter schon zum dritten takt und zwar
besagt dieser effekt das ist halt ein
paar tastenkombinationen gibt die ihr
eventuell noch nicht kannte und zwar zum
beispiel kennt es mit dem bogen und ich
schieß und ihr schießt und zum beispiel
im pvp bis nachher nicht wo ihre pfeile
gelandet sind wenn die gegner nicht
helfen ihr wollt euch die einsammeln und
ihr könnt einfach f3 gedrückt halten
dabei drücken und dann seht ihr die hit
boxen das geht auch wenn ich so ein fall
einfach weg schießen dann fliegt die hit
box quasi damit und ihr seht schon wenn
ich das spannende bin ich selbst einer
art hit box ziehen wir so bin ich immer
weil ich auch im verletzbarer gegenstand
hin und dann könnte dir ganz lang ganz
einfach einsammeln das funktioniert auch
im multiplayer und es ist halt locker
easy hier zum beispiel das schreiben
diese dings hier ist zum beispiel auch
eine hit box und jedes item ist eine hip
hop sind also bewegende sachen das heißt
dass krumbein
du bist doch creepy baumhaus zu gruppen
ab jetzt dicht gehalten bis creepy bist
echt verrückt so haben wir noch eins
noch einfacher
ich töte ich jetzt aber bogen skills
muss also da sieht man auf jeden fall
die hit box das ist sehr klar ihr könnt
dann wieder ausstellen indem ihr einfach
wieder f3 gedrückt haltet und bedrückt
das ist aber nicht die einzige
tastenkombination ersetzt geht wieder
sondern ich wollte ich auch noch die
tasten nachkommt das schmeiße ich im weg
wollte ich auch noch eine andere
tastenkombinationen zeigen und zwar kann
man f3 und h drücken und dann wieder f3
damit zahlt erst mal dieses drei
wegkommt und jetzt gehe ich zum beispiel
mal ein game bord 0
und jetzt achtet man ich habe eine ganze
menge diamant spitzhacke eisen spielzeug
und holz spitzhacke ich baue mit jedem
ein block ab
nachdem jetzt mal was hier angezeigt
wird braucht man
du musst chef hart durch das aufdrücken
luca soll jetzt wird hier nämlich die
dürre bildet ihr angezeigter steht 1560
von 1561 249 von 250 und 58 von 59 das
ist die haltbarkeit
das ist nicht auf deutsch übersetzt aber
es ist halt die haltbarkeit welche zb
mit nochmal ein abbau steht der
haltbarkeit 750 das etikett immer wie
viele mit einer spitzhacke noch abbauen
könnte das ist besonders auf höhen
trifft auf jeden fall sehr geil
damit ihr bei sowie abschätzen können
wie viele blöcke kann ich mit noch
abbauen bist mir neue machen muss
blablabla also ist auf jeden fall mega
chillig auch wieder ausmachen f3 + h so
ich geh mal wieder in game mode 1 und
was es auch noch gibt ihr könnt einfach
hashtag drücken und ihr seid direkt im
chat mit dem helm mit einem schrägstrich
drin das besonders gut wenn ihr auf der
serverseite irgend welche befehle
eingeben wollt müsst ihr nicht t und
dann shift gedrückt halten dann die
taste nach oben von ihr könnt einfach
hashtag drücken neben dementer und dann
habt ihr erhaltet ihr team so hashtag
times at 0 werden natürlich schon im
schnitt drin seit und hashtag drücker
das ist ganz normales hashtag #tatort
und dann sind wir auch direkt beim fun
fact uns was der fun fact diesmal sonnen
sondern revidieren vom letzten fun fact
und zwar beim letzten fun fact
felsenfest behauptet dass es nicht
funktioniert mit dem glas ton dass es
nicht mehr funktioniert das dir selbst
herausgefunden haben allerdings habe ich
vergessen hinter mich ein blog zu
stellen dass sich einzugraben den nehme
ich das nicht erst dann wenn dieser
block euch quasi wirklich zerdrückt mehr
oder weniger also so funktioniert das
wenn ihr euch das so aufbaut ist eine
sehr sanfte schaltung könnt ihr euch
einfach hier reinstellen ich glaube ich
könnte auch einfach mich hier noch einen
hoch stell dich doch das sollte auch
funktionieren ja und dann seid ihr hier
drin und ihr könnt dann wirklich durch
die welt durch gucken bei mir ist es
jetzt eine in minecraft generierte flat
world deswegen kann ich nichts sehen
allerdings kommt hier auch nicht so
leicht wieder raus msv auslaufen oder
wenn ihr euch halt wirklich ein grad und
dann eventuell dann zugedrückt wird dann
funktioniert das ganze halt auch nicht
übrigens wenn ich das mit was mach et
cetera werde ich als er drückt das
funktioniert hat alles nur mit los ton
und das war's mit der neuen fahren wenn
es euch gefallen würde ich mich freuen
wenn ihr das video mit einem daumen hoch
bewerten würde
bz meine kommentare schreiben könnte wie
euch allgemein so fun fact hat leider
bleibt bleibt bisher gefallen hat krimis
bester mann und ihr könnt mir auch
weiterhin perfekt in die kommentare
schreiben und eventuell werden die dann
im nächsten video vorgestellt ich würde
sagen euch noch ein wunderschönen tag
ich gehe erstmal duschen möchte total
fertig ausgleich eine fahrstunde
ich werde wahrscheinlich so fahren wie
in gta und dann erstmal zschau